[Musique]
c'est désormais un rendez vous annuel
qui lance en quelque sorte les grandes
vacances d'été emmanuel macron
s'exprimera lundi devant le congrès à
versailles des parlementaires n'y seront
pas d'autres attendent des réponses à
leurs questions qu'ils ne pourront pas
posé bonsoir à tous et à toutes le
congrès de versailles est en débat ce
soir c'est donc le deuxième acte du
discours présidentiel devant les
parlementaires comme il ya tout juste un
an et comme cela devrait être le cas en
2019 2020 2021 et peut-être plus encore
le président de la république va
s'adresser à la nation via ses
représentants élus les débats ont déjà
commencé sur le coût d'une telle
convocation son intérêt politique aussi
la france insoumise préfère rester à
l'assemblée nationale certains
parlementaires aient l'air en
circonscription que faut-il attendre de
ce rendez vous à quoi sert-il
concrètement nous allons poser ces
questions à nos invités du soir stéphane
manceau enseignant en droit et sciences
politiques à lui vécu marie le bec
député de la république en marche des
yvelines grand dîner moscow porte parole
de la france insoumise sur saint quentin
en yvelines et puis martha de sidrac va
nous rejoindre dans quelques instants
sénatrice elle l'est républicain des
yvelines bonsoir à vous où ça
alors j'avais une première question pour
martha de cidre avec ça tombe bien je
vais commencer avec vous randy nemos
puisque c'est la france a soumises qui a
décidé une nouvelle fois de boycotter ce
congrès vous vous n'êtes pas élu mais
j'imagine que vous soutenez ce choix là
et est-ce que vous souteniez aussi les
termes utilisés par exemple par eric
coquerel qui dénonce un monarque sa
majesté et des méthodes de l'ancien
régime ce alors que c'est la révision de
2008 qui permet au président de parler
devant le congrès oui bien sûr que je
soutiens ce congrès il ne sert pas à
grand chose c'est à dire que vous avez
monsieur macron qui va venir devant les
parlementaires dicter un petit peu sa
politique la politique qui va avoir lieu
l'année suivante
mais ça va coûter en pognon
de dengue est en soi et variés en sortir
parce que rappaz de dialogue il n'y aura
pas de références pognon 2 1 ils ont
replacé la révérence à cette fameuse
vidéo qui qui était sur les réseaux
sociaux
marie le bec tout de suite je me tourne
vers vous qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ces vagues qu'on entend depuis depuis
quelques semaines maintenant je pense
que c'est important le président vient
faire un bilan de l'année écoulée et des
perspectives dans les années à venir de
l'action qu'il a menée qui conduit avec
son son gouvernement vous savez il fait
la même chose avec les membres du
gouvernement il les reçoit il fait le
bilan avec eux on est représentant de la
nation je pense que c'est important
justement qu'on soit un moment on est un
temps d'échangé avec le président de la
république
et puis par ailleurs sur est ce que ça
va coûter ça ne coûte rien en fait ça
coûte c'est sur le budget de non c'est
pas 500 mille euros parce qu'il n'y a
pas encore de chiffres qui ont été
publiés par le sénat et par l'assemblée
nationale selon le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale qui participe aux frais la
sécurité de l'argent mais je vais dire
tout ce qu'ils auraient présidentielle
coûte de l'argent aurait pu le faire sur
à la télévision ça aurait coûté beaucoup
moins d'argent si c'était juste pour
dire ce qu'il allait faire pendant un an
et les parlementaires peuvent très bien
regarder ça de chez eux il vient
s'exprimer oui mais on parle aussi on
peuvent aussi voter de chez nous on peut
aussi ne jamais ce qui fait la force de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat s'est
carrément ils sont réunis ensemble pour
échanger soit chacun de leur côté soit
séparément sur le congrès pour pas
rentrer dans une bataille de chiffres
ce qu'il faut je pense rappeler c'est
que ces prélevés sur le budget assemblée
nationale et sénat et par ailleurs les
coûts sont très variables en fonction
des années d'ailleurs il ya un député de
la république en mars qui a dit qu'il
n'irait pas c'est paul molac député du
morbihan
ça fait tâche un peu quand même oui on
peut que le déplorer moi je pense que
c'est important honnêtement qu'il y ait
ce temps en fin de session gars
énormément de réformes qui ont été
conduites et aussi vers quoi la france
se dirige se projette dont les quatre
années à venir qu'il reste au
quinquennat mais aussi des noms l'année
et qui arrive
martha de ces dragons soir pour les
républicains certains aussi élus ont dit
qu'ils n'iront pas lundi à versailles
qu'il est votre choix vous est-ce que
vous irez chercher à faire oui alors ce
n'est pas la seule raison
un surnom je pense qu'il est important
que le parlement se réunisse ça a été
d'ailleurs l'une des promesses du
président lorsqu'il a été élu ils m'ont
le seul regret que j'ai c'est que nous
les parlementaires nous n'allons pas
nous exprimer à ce moment là ça ne sera
pas véritablement un dialogue mais c'est
l'exercice qui venant l'ars de parole
ans après le tout à fait pour les que
pour les présidents des commissions en
effet ils pourront s'exprimer
donc pour répondre et simplement à votre
question oui j'irai à ce congrès l'a
bien évidemment stéphane minson est-ce
qu est-ce que c'est utile concrètement
selon vous ce genre de ce genre de
rendez vous ou alors c'est plutôt de la
communication c'est forcément les deux
mais c'est utile
je pense que c'est d'abord utile parce
que le constituant la estimé utile en
il faut il faut préciser puisque on
parle souvent comme l'an dernier de
dérives monarchiques ou voir monarchiste
c'est que tout bon jour et le cas avec
les présidents de la vème république on
a souvent dit ça les oppositions souvent
disent ah oui et puis lorsque les
oppositions se sont retrouvés dans la
majorité
le discours a changé le fait est que
c'est tout sauf monarchiste puisque ce
qui était d'inspiration monarchique voir
monarchiste s'était en effet
l'interdiction formulée au chef de
l'état de pénétrer dans le lieu où se
trouvaient les les les assemblées et
c'était la crainte en 1872 73 que le
président de l'époque qui avait tourné
casaque de monarchistes qui étaient
devenus républicains viennent en quelque
sorte convaincre les parlementaires qui
était monarchiste à l'époque d'opter
pour la république donc le
rétablissement en 2008 de cette
possibilité qui avait existé avant
permis au chef de l'état de s'exprimer
dans les parlementaires est un acte
fondamentalement erronée moseley pas
convaincu pour autant je suppose je peux
être que je peux être d'accord avec vous
pour moi monsieur macron il n'est pas
dans la posture d'un monarque absolu
alors c'est un petit peu la symbolique
qu'il essaie de mettre en place tout de
même il se construit l'image d'un homme
faure qui dirige le pays d'une gamme
assez autoritaire il sait où il va ça
pour moi c'est un cache misère c'est à
dire que de toute façon toute la
politique de monsieur macron c'est ça il
se fait passer pour un écolo parce qu'en
réalité il produit une politique
complètement anti écologiste
là c'est pareil il se fait passer pour
un homme fort mais quand il va à
l'extérieur quand il rencontre monsieur
trump quand il faut aller négocier dans
l'union européenne
là y'a plus personne parce qu'au final
ce n'est pas un monarque absolu c'est un
valet absolue voilà ce que c'est
monsieur mc ren il est aux ordres de
l'union européenne de la commission
européenne des lobbystes de l'union
européenne et de l'oligarchie financière
économique il a mis en place marine le
pen peut être une réponse rapidement
avant de passer sur le fond a peut-être
de ce nom je reviens à justin très
rapidement sur ce que martin de cédric
faisait effectivement je j'ai entendu ce
matin de vos coups de la part de vos
confrères une idée intéressante de dire
peut-être que les présidents de groupe
devrait s'exprimer avant et finalement
que le sortant des rangs soit presque 1
une réponse même si le président arrive
avant après ces deux pouvoirs séparés le
pouvoir législatif et le pouvoir
exécutif
la constitution est fait de telle sorte
que effectivement il n'y ait pas de
réponse directe au président mais
peut-être que le fait d'avoir les
groupes parlementaires qui
s'exprimeraient de prime abord
permettrait voilà d'avoir d'ores et déjà
la position de fin l'état un petit peu
la température avant que le président
rentre après sûr je pense
qu'effectivement emmanuel maintenant
elle a rappelé à plusieurs reprises mais
c'est pas c'est comme vous l'avez très
bien dit le gâteau ce côté un petit
monarchique dans la vème république le
le président l'avait déjà dit à
plusieurs fois qu'il y avait une sorte
de désespoir un petit peu des français
on cherche un peu toujours l'homme fort
de la vème république donc je pense que
il veut l'incarner et je vous aurais que
ça commençait delà des élections avec
cette arrivée je pense qu'il le fait il
le fait très bien il y avait une attente
notamment après le quinquennat de
françois hollande d'avoir une direction
qui soit deux états souverains cap c'est
assumé on l'a vu senna ça fait partie de
notre méthode on prend des décisions
notre dame des landes la réforme de la
sncf et on les fait appliquer rapidement
c'était pas de mensonge si vous vouliez
réagir là-dessus on va passer sur le
font du bruit sauf que là on est
vraiment sur le fond des institutions de
la vème république
je sais ce qu'a voulu le peuple en 1958
c'est ce que manifestement il le veut
toujours je crois alors on peut être
pour ou contre
dire que oui c'est pas la vision de tout
le monde sauf que jusqu'à présent c'est
plutôt il ya eu c'est vrai un besoin en
france alors on peut le déplorer d'avoir
comme un grain guide un chef ce nom mais
par annoncer pas scientifique du tour 66
appelle la politique c'est un fait c'est
tout on n'en sait pas si ces bâtisses et
puis on va peut-être à pleuvoir les
informations s'affichent et que cette
prise de parole d'un président devant le
parlement a été rendue possible par une
révision de la constitution en 2008 sous
nicolas sarkozy et que lui-même en 2009
françois hollande en novembre 2015 après
les attentats et donc emmanuel macron
l'an passé l'ont convoqué ça devrait se
répéter dans les années à venir marc tu
as sidra pour parler des attentes sur ce
congrès vous y seraient pour la première
fois à ce congrès quelles sont vos
attentes est-ce que vous avez des
interrogations particulière à propos de
la politique du gouvernement et des
manuels macron alors des attentes j'en
ai beaucoup et je pense que je ne suis
pas la seule à en avoir donc lan je
dirais cette question là est vaste donc
on pourrait en débattre
l'art est la momie traditionnelle par
exemple qui vous intéresse puisque les
discussions vont commencer le lendemain
à que je pense que ça pourrait être
l'occasion je parle au conditionnel
puisque je ne savais pas du tout encore
forcément de quoi va nous parler le
président macron mais moi je suis en
attente et je ne suis pas la seule d'une
vision je voudrais savoir précisément
toutes ces réformes qui ce pour
certaines n'ont pas tenu tout à fait
leurs promesses aujourd'hui j'ai ben là
je sors c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous prie de m'excuser je suis arrivé un
petit peu en retard
on travaille sur le projet de loi des
violences sexuelles faites aux femmes en
fins sexuelles et sexistes que vous avez
déjà examiné à l'assemblée
je pense également à la réforme la
réforme
sur le numérique qui n'a pas abouti en
fait chez nous à adopter pas du tout
examiné je pense à un certain nombre de
projets de loi aussi de propositions de
loi et notamment les propositions de
lois qui vont dans le sens je pense à la
loi élan qui arrivent chez nous un que
vous avez point sa part un peu dans tous
les sens yonne là on sort de la loi par
exemple sénat de la loi et galim qui est
un petit peu une loi fourre tout ça va
ça à bord tellement de choses qu'au bout
d'un moment on perd un petit peu le fil
conducteur de tout cela la loi élan pour
aisne alors moi je suis sur les sujets
numériques donc évidemment c'est quelque
chose qui m'intéresse beaucoup
initialement soixante cinq articles dont
5 simplement sur le volet numérique
sachant que au sénat je pense que madame
le bec le sait nous avons voté à
l'unanimité une loi sur le numérique qui
ont plus concerne fortement notre
département les yvelines qui est un
petit peu aujourd'hui aux oubliettes on
nous avait promis que celle là ça allait
revenir grâce à la loi élan à l'ordre du
jour aujourd'hui moi je suis très
clairement déçu par sa donc quand je
vous disais un petit peu vision
j'aimerais un petit peu voir où nous
allons avec quelles méthodes
parce que là aussi je m'interroge un
tout petit peu donc oui j'ai vous avez
des informations à nous communiquer sur
ce qui va être
lundi à versailles appris de sources
plus ou moins sur ce dossier le
président réécrire à son discours
jusqu'à la veille jusqu'à la dernière
minute
donc c'est non mais c'est pas ça ne ça
n'a pas du tout fuite et je trouve
parlera même de du projet de loi
constituent l'actualité du moment
alors je pense que ça reviendra
certainement s'il y avait un bilan qui
devait être dressée mille fois oblique
au projet doit consommer en fait il
l'avait évoqué dans son premier discours
devant le congrès d'ailleurs il a pris
un peu de retard puisqu'à la base
c'était censé être bouclé au bout d'un
an on est au bout d'un an et les
discussions ont commencé seulement à la
santé alors ça on peut tout à fait le
déplorer mais l'agenda législatif est
absolument plein je pense qu'on partage
décidera quels voilà c'était un certain
nombre de réformes
donc c'est très très intense en termes
de rythme et on a toujours cette
contrainte d'avoir à la fois le temps au
débat et en même temps de vue-là de
tenir le rythme des réformes sur
lesquelles on s'est engagé mais l'idée
c'est peut-être de présenter dans ce
congrès la prochaine grande loi qui va
arriver là dedans en 2019
la réforme des retraites ce sera
peut-être la réforme des retraites on a
aussi des lois structurantes qui vous
est débattu d'ici la fin de l'année je
pense notamment à impacter j'espère donc
il y aura des dispositions sur le sur le
numérique parce que effectivement c'est
fondamental mais voilà l'idée c'est
peut-être aussi de présenter la
prochaine lendemain randy nemo c'est ce
que vous allez quand même regarder vous
attentivement ce qui va être dit lundi
oui bien sûr on va regarder c'est quand
même le président de la république
pour autant nous ce qu'on attendrait pas
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure que
les français allaient voulue par le
peuple avait voulu cette vème république
une place de second degré il ya eu
énormément de réforme constitutionnelle
dont celle de 2008
et pourtant on n'a jamais demandé au
peuple de se prononcer par référendum
sur ces changements
donc on aimerait par exemple qu'ils
aient le courage d'annoncer un
référendum sur ce changement
constitutionnel sur cette réforme
constitutionnelle voilà parce que c'est
pas notre en effet c'est pas notre
vision de la démocratie celle d'un homme
fort qui aurait tous les pouvoirs et
tillie qui dirigerait la france vient de
faire non nous sommes pour la 6ème
république
nous sommes pour le référendum
d'initiative populaire
nous sommes pour
révocabilité des élus et nous sommes
aussi pour la règle verte parlons un
petit peu d'écologie c'est à dire c'est
une règle qui dit d'inscrire dans la
constitution quand qu'on ne peut pas
prendre à la terre plus que ce qu'elle
produit en une année voilà stéphane
mamans sont vous en tant qu'observateur
chercheurs qu'est ce que vous attendez
de ce congrès sur sur le fond quelles
sont les questions qui vous viennent vos
interrogations à vous ce que j'attends
de ce congrès rien cependant si ce que
j'en ai pensé que je regarderai et puis
c'est un moment républicain puisse et je
voyais autant le quinquennat sarkozy m'a
paru très critiquable sur de nombreux
points autant cette révision constitue l
de 2008 moi je les approuve et parce que
ça se fait dans beaucoup de grandes
démocraties qui a besoin de rénover
souvent la constitution selon vous il ya
dix ans ça paraît pas si non alors le
temps s'accélère sur la question sont
des questions différentes quand vous
disiez tout à l'heure à la députée que
cette ça traînait un peu cette révision
constitue l forte heureusement on fait
on a l'habitude de dire on touche à la
constitution que d'une main tremblante
il ya eu 25 26 révision depuis 1958
alors je sais pas c'est pas au kg 1 mais
on ne modifie pas on ne révise pas la
constitution tous les quatre matins
landes ya peut-être une habitude un peu
un peu fâcheuses qui a été prise que
chaque président de la république désire
laisser son nom à une révision
constitutionnelle mais en tout cas il ya
suffisamment de souplesse dans la
constitution pour que celle ci ne soit
pas révisée en permanence en tout cas on
suppose que ce projet de loi sera
évoquée par le président ce projet de
loi est critiquée notamment par gérard
larcher sénateur des yvelines président
du sénat est ce que c'est votre cas
aussi on va rappeler les points
essentiels du projet de loi
constitutionnelle suppression de la cour
de la justice de la république de
justice de la république suppression
notamment
ça peut paraître comme ça anodin mais du
mot race dans le premier article
réduction du nombre d'amendements -
navette par le moteur aussi pour
faciliter le travail législatif
c'est très critiquée par gérard larcher
qui est de votre parti qui aussi de
votre département est ce que vous aussi
vous êtes inquiète là dessus alors oui
je suis inquiète parce qu'en fait en
disant cela en réalité c'est notre toute
autre procédure tout notre prof
démocratique qui pourrait être ébranlée
et je pense que là dessus il faut que
nous soyons collectivement tous assez
vigilant et que nous fassions attention
à cela
donc diminuer le
réduire les amendements en fait que l'on
pourrait proposer en discussion en fait
on touche au coeur même de ce qu'est le
travail d'un parlementaire puisque
madame le bec le sait très bien vous le
savez tous autour de cette table là nous
avons un rôle en fait de ce qu'on me dit
de fabriquer la loi de contrôler
l'exécutif est aussi de proposer aussi
un des textes donc dès lors que l'on
enlève cette possible une d1 des
maillots en fait de ce process nous
touchons à l'ensemble du dispositif et
là dessus je pense qu'il faut que nous
soyons vraiment tous collectivement au
delà de ce que vous avez insisté sur le
fait aujourd'hui non tout ne fonctionne
non tout ne fonctionne pas mais ce pour
autant qu'il faille tout tout remettre à
zéro et repartir complètement parce que
derrière cette réduction et 7
je dirais cette limitation du travail
des parlementaires ont véritablement en
touche en fait à l'expression
démocratique de notre pays et je pense
que les tuiles faut que nous soyons tous
vigilants
donc je ne suis pas contre une réforme
mais très clairement là il ya quelques
lignes rouges comme le dit le président
larcher qui auquel il faudra faire
attention et qu'il ne faudra pas
franchir un petit peu vite
marie lebel j'imagine que on vous en
parle souvent de cette réforme de la
constitution
c'est dans ce même temps le plus souvent
c'est la diminution du nombre de
parlementaires mais oui c'est vrai c'est
pas meilleure avec cet argument qui peut
se comprendre d'avoir au moins un
sénateur ou un député par parra pardon
oui oui bien sûr et je crois de réaliser
les modalités de redécoupage sont très
très encadré et très précise donc l'idée
c'est pas du tout de d'avoir un
parlementaire enfin un sénateur ou un
député comme
on en a peut-être moins mais qui couvre
tout un département il n est pas du tout
de faire ça et dotations les questions
de représentativité sont extrêmement
très précisément défini donc il ya un
enjeu sur le sujet moi j'entends tout à
fait que la réforme inquiète parce que
je suis très attaché à la constitution
de la vème république donc je veux qu'on
la révise pas pour la 6ème république
mais je suis surtout attaché au fait qu
on la réalise avec prudence avec
parcimonie que le débat ait lieu et que
effectivement on puisse trouver
l'équivalent consensus parce qu'il faut
que les deux chambres qui vont du coup
représenter le peuple se trouve bien
représentés moi je trouve quand même que
il ya il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
c'est que c'était pas le limiter
l'expression démocratique même si
j'entends le débat autour de la
réduction d'amendements mais n'empêche
que quand vous arrivez mois sur la loi
agriculture on a des maîtres la loi et
lens est à peu près les mêmes
proportions
pas loin de 3 milliards mandement pour
chaque loi je peux vous dire que le
débat n'existe pas parce qu'en réalité
vous ne mangez un objectif c'est d'aller
au bout des 3 milliards moment c'est
extrêmement long juste il faut quand
même dire qu'on renforce le pouvoir de
contrôle du parlement ce qui est aussi
bien ce qu'on a tendance à sur légiférer
en france et ont peut-être contrôler la
mise en application n'est pas un mal
martin de cette affaire durant dean est
mort oui moi très simplement je voudrais
revenir sur le fait de faim sur
l'argument de dire vous voyez il ya
tellement d'amendements déposés que le
débat n'a pas lieu et donc supprimant
les amendements la vraie question que
l'on doit se poser dans cette période je
dirais d'embouteillage et législatif
parce qu'on a un certain nombre de
textes et ce n'est pas fini
c'est de se poser la question pourquoi
en autant de textes alors que nous en
avons qui sont prêts qui ont été adoptés
pas l'une des chambres et qui ne sont
pas examinés par les autres et on nous
dit attendez un petit peu ça va revenir
je reviens excusez moi je suis un tout
petit peu opiniâtre sur un certain
nombre de textes depuis le début de
l'année nous avons voté et adopté trois
textes fondamentaux au sénat est la
réponse qui nous est fait à chaque fois
c'est de dire attendons parce que ça va
revenir avec le texte du gouvernement
pas de problème sauf qu'à un moment
donné il ne faudrait pas que l'on se
fasse piéger nous les parlementaires par
cette façon de faire de l'exécutif parce
qu'en réalité l'ordre du jour finalement
par cet embouteillage législatif nous
est un tout petit peu imposée par le par
le gouvernement donc voila moi je suis
un tout petit peu critique par rapport à
cet argument un peu facile de dire vous
voyez il ya tellement d'un moment c'est
parce que les lois sont faites dans
l'urgence et que les parlementaires font
leur job
excusez moi d'utiliser ce mot là et donc
il faut bien évidemment amende et
parfois certains textes en jean et
montez vous semblez d'accord avec une
scène
oui parce que défendre et tout
simplement le bon sens de la démocratie
on est en train de nous expliquer avec
la république en marche qu'en supprimant
des députés en ayant moins de députés
par dans la démocratie leur aussi de
sénateurs aussi alors nous on est pour
la suppression du sénat rose pas contre
vous mais voilà la fenêtre démocratie
fonctionnerait mieux avec moins de
députés mais c'est complètement absurde
vous éloigner encore plus le pouvoir des
citoyens alors quand c'est bien que le
lien entre les citoyens et les élus et
et est en train de se déliter très
fortement et vous renforcer le pouvoir
du président qui a déjà énormément de
force ça n'a aucun sens démocratique et
non se battre à l'open 60 go quand même
quand on prend le pouls comme ça quand
on interroge les gens les l'opinion
alors en tout cas sur ce point là sur
moins de parlementaires a l'air plutôt
d'accord avec la volonté des ports prévu
pour moi les pays ils ont ils peuvent
faire comme françois ruffin qui se
payent au smic
après nous on supprime le sénat donc ça
fait aussi des économies mais il ya un
petit peu cette démagogie qui est
utilisé contre les parlementaires mais
c'est dangereux parce que ça renforce le
pouvoir d'un seul homme qui a déjà
énormément de pouvoir dans la vème
république contradicteurs ce que disent
qu'on visite d'un côté on veut pas moins
de parlementaires mais on veut supprimer
le sénat avait de fait vous en supprimer
300 je veux dire c'est plus de députés
c'est différent on peut plus de député
parce que les sénateurs les sénateurs ne
sont pas élus directement aux suffrages
non non non mais janot suffrage
universel direct donc nous voulons plus
de députés donc plus d'expression de la
souveraineté populaire directe alors ma
conviction intime là on va pas être
d'accord je suis désolé c'est que les
deux chambres sont nécessaires
aujourd'hui les réellement les deux
chambres sont tout à fait nécessaire et
parfaitement complémentaires puisque
nous avons les députés qui sont en lien
direct avec leur territoire à travers
les concitoyens qu'ils représentent et
nous mêmes nous sommes en lien direct
avec nos territoires à travers les élus
qui eux-mêmes représente leur propre
leurs propres concitoyens et ce n'est
pas dû au point de rejoindre débat sur
la suppression du sénat parce que je
crois que ça sera pas engagé de toute
façon très très rapide je voulais
peut-être l'éclairer mon voisin qui ne
qui achève de geeks et imaginer des gens
qui sont tirés au sort et je voulais
poser une question est ce que c'est
l'occasion aussi pour emmanuel macron de
peut-être de recadrer les choses on a
l'impression depuis quelques quelques
semaines qu'il y a kylie a décroît que
les sondages sont en baisse il ya des
difficultés avec les collectivités on
sait il ya les 80 km/heure à la
croissance qui semble quelque peu
ralenti en 2018
les difficultés sur l'europe est ce que
ceci aussi de rappeler l'occasion de
rappeler que que voilà tout va bien et
qu'il contrôle la situation selon vous
qui a des difficultés enfin je pense
qu'il s'en doutait mais de fait pour
rassurer les élus rationnelle à la
population je rassurer la population
enfin en effet il aurait pu le faire à
la télévision il le fait très bien ou
non mais je pense que c'est l'exercice
l'exercice est avant tout un exercice
symbolique
je crois qu'il a rien à recadrer du tout
enfin si recadrage elia s'est pas là
c'est pas là qu'il faut le faire et je
crois que c'est pas là que le président
de la république compte le faire c'est
un moment symbolique
on peut prendre ça aussi vous parler un
peu de mépris vis-à-vis des
parlementaires etc
dans d'autres cultures jeunes aux états
unis d'amérique par exemple c'est le
discours sur l'état de l'union qui est
prononcée en janvier par le par le
président des états unis devant le
congrès c'est-à-dire le sénat et la
chambre des représentants s'est pris au
contraire comme une forme de respect
vis-à-vis de 2,2 du corps parlementaire
donc on peut le prendre aussi dans ceux
dans ce sens-là recadrage nous il ya
aussi cette idée des quelques réflexions
parfois malheureuses qui peuvent choquer
l'opinion à la faire du pognon qui a été
souligné par randy nemo je pense que le
risque zéro gage reprendre la main le
registre langage qui sera utilisée
devant le congrès du parlement sera un
peu gonflé son père oui mais je n'en
doute pas non je pense que oui
effectivement tout ne peut rien c'est
normal vient on est dans une situation
internationale il ya un an c'était le
premier congrès l'impression que tu
allais bien parce qu'il ya il ya un nom
il ya eu une vague d'espoir qui était
portée par mâcon je pense pas du tout
qu'elle souhaitait mais par contre
effectivement déjà on a des oppositions
qui se restructurent alors qu'elle était
un petit peu
choquée peut-être par par la victoire de
manuel mâcon par la victoire aussi au
niveau du parlement
et puis oui la situation internationale
est compliqué il faut se retrousser les
manches il ya des envois sur l'europe
mais c'est aussi là que en tant que
parlementaire on semble on se sent le
plus utile parce qu'on agit pour notre
pays et on agit pour justement avec le
gouvernement avec le président pour
essayer chacun avec nos voix différente
mais pour essayer de justement de que ça
aille mieux en français aux niveaux
nationaux européens et internationaux
alors rapidement tous les deux mais sa
parole à l'opposition pour conclure le
débat les yeux va tellement bien que
monsieur le président se permet de
reporter l'annoncé de son plan anti
pauvreté à après l'été étant donné
qu'elle a coulé en ondes par leur
envergure cette histoire c'est sûr plus
important que la pauvre dit moi je
voudrais juste rajouter que j'ai un
grand espoir quand même et j'attends
énormément c'est la baisse des dépenses
la baisse des dépenses n'est pas encore
amorcé et ça ça m'inquiète profondément
donc réforme luis nécessaire en revanche
il ne faudra pas du tout oublier que
nous sommes un pays qui sont des tous
les jours ça continue et pour l'instant
je n'en vois pas la mort ce en fait je
ne vois pas lundi qui cite des réponses
non et on verra les additions autre
suivra le congrès sur tv soit
scientifique merci à vous casser la fin
de ce 7 8 le débat prochaine émission
jeudi prochain à 18h30 en direct
d'ici là vous retrouvez cette émission
replay sur tv 78 points comme ou
l'application tv 78
merci à tous et bonne soirée
[Musique]